almost every day for two months erica
received a text message that her dear
friend jt was ok i didn't know
when he left for ukraine
if i if i ever would see him again in
march the 50-year-old recently retired
canadian veteran traveled to ukraine to
join the fight a couple of months later
his truck hit an anti-tank mine jt was
rushed to hospital clinging to life i
was really scared erica spent weeks
trying to arrange his rescue but was
told the canadian government couldn't
help and a private air evacuation was
too expensive
so she called a lifeline he's one of us
i mean you know no no man left behind
this veteran served in the same brigade
as jt in kandahar he and others have
spent the past year rescuing refugees
from afghanistan and ukraine then in may
they learned one of their own was in
trouble jt was badly injured in hospital
close to the front line and far from any
border you've got a wounded guy in
ukraine there's no government support
available so how do you get somebody
back from a situation like that this
really was a canadian team effort over
several weeks the group of veterans and
health workers came up with a plan jt
was transferred between six different
ukrainian hospitals before finally
catching a flight out of warsaw and last
week he touched down here in toronto
it was very emotional
super amazing to get to see him again it
was an enormous
an enormous sense of relief
global news spoke to jt whose last name
were withholding by phone from his
hospital bed it's impossible for me to
not get emotional um because
you know if i talk about alone
the amount of people that have come
forward to assist me he suffered a
broken neck fractured ribs burns a
concussion and nerve damage but
incredibly he says he doesn't regret his
decision to go
i saw families being torn apart you know
you want to get out there and help
because i have the ability to do so
it's it's one mind that doesn't find a
child
or a family or
like i'm good now on a long road to
recovery but grateful to be alive jeff
semple global news toronto